hey welcome back
good to see you
let's talk about social groups
social groups are kind of like
the building blocks of any conversation about sociology
right the majority of things we talk about
whether we're talking about deviants
or marriage in the family or what have you
it often comes back to social groups
um so what is a social group
like how we define a social group
and what are the elements of a social group right
um we think of social groups
I always like
this this definition
that they are collections of people
who interact on a regular basis with one another
and are aware of their status within a group
and a group can be anything from 2 people
a DIAD to more than 2 people right
um but they have to be aware that they're in the group
I always love that part of the definition
that cracks me up
so whenever I'm teaching class
and I think of that example
so I think of this example
like if you're in a relationship with somebody
that's a social group
if it's 2 people
you're in a relationship
that's a social group
but you're both aware that you're in that relationship
that's one of the elements that makes it a social group
so the example I give in class
which always cracks students up
is that you know
if you have a stalker who's stalking somebody
and they're following that person
they may think they're in a social group
but the other person's not aware of them being stopped
or in that relationship
so that's not a social group
it's not a relationship
it's just a felony
in most states
um so there's lots of elements of social groups
though right
there are different kinds of social groups
there's what we call primary social groups
and secondary social groups
primary social groups are people
in which we have regular contact with
their enduring long term relationships
they may know your birthday
your family members your pets
they know lots of things about you
whereas secondary relationships are
people that we have more of a secondary relationship
I may go into Starbucks
every single day
and see the same people
and they know my name
which they do
and they know my coffee
which is nice
but they don't know my birthday
they don't know things about me
out of a personal nature
we don't interact
and have that type of relationship
it's more secondary
but this is interesting to think about
because historically humans
if you think about the hunting and gathering society
the agricultural or agrarian era
humans often lived in communities
which there were mostly primary groups
or primary relationships
it isn't until you get into the Industrial Revolution
and you get into urbanization
that we really shift into more
relationships
or interactions that are more secondary in nature
or secondary groups
so think just a simple example
getting gas in your car
if you live in a small town
in United States
a rural town
um I remember in college
I dated this girl
out in a small town
near the Mississippi
you go to get gas in your car there
um the experience of getting gas
you walk in the store
to pay for your gas
which you have to
in those towns right
uh the person at the cash register
knows everything about you
knows your parents
knows that your
when your dad died
was probably at the funeral
is gonna ask you
how your sister's doing
like they know
that's a primary relationship
if you get gas
in Chicago tomorrow
you don't talk to anybody
you put your card in the meter right
actually if somebody were to talk to you
it would feel odd or uncomfortable
we don't have as many primary relationships
so sociologists have been fascinated by that shift
right where humans previously lived
in communities in which we had more primary groups
or primary relationships
and in this more modern era
we tend to in our urban or suburban communities
live in situations
where our relationships are in secondary groups
and are more secondary in nature
just something to think about
we'll see you next time